I'm going to tell you something really
hard I want you to internalize this deep
in your soul okay okay he left you a
long time
ago yeah your dad abandoned you like a
coward and left you the problem is he's
such an extra layer of weak cowardly
man that he left a ribbon out his shut
door for his daughter to hold on to yeah
think when I when I cut ties with him I
was making that choice to not allow him
to hurt me anymore and to just control
what I could control and that doesn't
mean you did the right thing and we
often think that if we do the right
thing the world just works out you can
do the right thing and it still hurts
real real bad